tenzen of cattle I run a sustainable
travel company called the blue yonder
associates and I'm here as a global
shaper from the Mumbai hub the forum
this year has been extremely excellent
with its not only brought us to go Gao
which is completely unique from Bombay
last year but at the same point of time
it's really given us a great opportunity
especially speaking on behalf of young
people to interact with world leaders
and not only world leaders who only look
at us as young people but also people
who actually have opinions who have
views and take them into regard so it's
been extremely inspiring very very
rewarding enough take I'm taking back a
load of conversations a lot of insights
and experiences as food for thought back
home which I'm going to definitely kind
of like look at and implement in my own
company so I think it's been absolutely
great